I'm going to select the first five,
and then right click,
and I'll choose "Remove Other Columns".
Now, the only columns remaining are the five that I've selected.
Let's take a look at these data types.
It looks like Power BI has done us a favor and selected each of these correctly.
Category is chosen for type Text, so is Commodity.
Then over here for the PLU number,
it's selected this 123,
which means Whole Number.
You might ask yourself whether you should keep the PLU as a number or
as a text so you don't have to worry about it summing up in the report.
For now, I think I'm going to go ahead and leave it as a number in case I want to
filter produce based on PLU value ranges later on.
I'll just include delta sum when I get to reporting.
Let's move on to the Store Calendar.
Here on the Store Calendar,
I'm going to promote the headers and then I'm going to take over for Power BI with type.
I'm going to click here to choose Date as my selected data type for Date,
and for Month and Year,
I'm going to choose "Whole Number".
Whole Number gives us the option to also select greater than or less than.
It's useful to have the number type for both of these.
Finally, on Sales, I'm going to change the Date column to type Date,
PLU column to type Whole Number,
Amount to Fixed Decimal, to again,
avoid fractions of pennies in our calculations,
Cost to Fixed Decimal as well,
and Subtotal finally as Fixed Decimal.
Now I have my demo file all tidied up with the right number types,
and it's your turn to give it a shot.